this is like there's a scene in twilight
that made me
react how you're reacting that's the
gayest [ __ ] you said i know yeah right
i was going to defend you and then you
said this reminds me of twilight that's
that's a problematic
series fam yeah yeah i don't know if
y'all seen him uh problematic no
i don't know can i see twice he's using
words like problem matters
that [ __ ] is problematic like super like
how was it triggering two was triggering
his trigger
say it was triggering like i felt
triggered watching that [ __ ] dog
i don't even like saying that word
because that's just close
insane that white people love saying
that triggering because you got
bricked up by the world wrecked
up dude by these vampires not a wolf guy
now the wolf
[Laughter]
who got you who got more bricks out of
you yo he would like team jacob
jacob though he's a beast also if you
were in the wide what's the time of the
podcast right now
if you were just in the wide go back a
little bit what you just bought
again no i did that was
[Applause]
and he went like this he actually turned
his head a little bit more when he went
to
go behind the mic now he went a little
real quick there's a moment in twilight
right like where
bella the the shorty whatever her name
is kristen stewart right
bella finds out some [ __ ] or something
is exposed about edward's past that he
never told her no he has to like tell
her something he never told her about
him
right and after he became a vampire this
is the news he breaks her like the news
is about to break her heart
and make her think that she don't know
if she can be with this guy because he's
morally bankrupt he's the baby right
there's no way that she could possibly
be with him this is the thing
it goes back and it plays this like past
history [ __ ] where he's out here and
he's biting humans
right and you think that he's just
hunting like regular humans
but it turns out he was hunting like
rapists and serial killers and that kind
of [ __ ] like that
so like the moment where he's about to
be a piece of [ __ ] turns out he's even
more heroic
and i had the reaction that you had was
like i was like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
perfect you literally want to spend
forever with this girl like that's what
he said this is the
ideal scenario for any woman right like
i just want to spend not only the rest
of my life i want to spend forever
they're vampires they don't die they
literally spend forever
like your life isn't enough the [ __ ]
who wrote this movie is absolutely
psychotic
that's definitely meyer stephanie is
absolutely psychotic we can't just spend
just life it's
it can't even be until death do us part
no there ain't no part
there's no partner bro i'm watching this
[ __ ] so that scene comes on i'm like
what the [ __ ] and then up for whatever
reason i get into this movie
the jacob character right this movie's
problematic let's jacob first of all my
man is 100 years old now
he's 100 years old dating a 16 year old
that's not really we've spent this much
time on this he didn't have a podcast
when it came out
that's what happened that's not weird
that edward's character
is 100 years old dating a 16 year old
that's not weird he's 100 years old
going to high school
and hitting on 16 year olds that's not
weird that's not awkward that's not
weird just because he looks
he looks good he knows he could be in
college right now
exactly go to college yeah you can [ __ ]
regular age [ __ ] if you want and it's
actually more reasonable he goes to
college if he's 100 years old the age
of consent was younger then it don't
matter he's now
that's good don't go back into consent
markets
do not be making [ __ ] arguments for
this man so then i'm like all right this
is super weird but i'm gonna let it go
all right whatever we'll get past it
right
then the wolf jacob jacob
hottie the hottie with the body right
wolves do this thing i guess called
imprinting where you just choose your
mate and then that's your mate that's
the person you're meant to be with and
it's not even happening you're
controlling
i hate it you're about to hate it even
more but not even up to your control you
just see somebody and you
imprint on them and that's it you cannot
do anything about it and that's it
forever
i [ __ ] you not i don't know how this is
not a [ __ ] huge news story
where's cnn cnn where are you this is a
this is a problem hello what is fox news
the mainstream media is so [ __ ] bro
dude where's q1 q9 should be all over
the [ __ ] is going on
alex jones
oh you got all the way up to jacob
you saw when it came out you [ __ ]
my man jacob sees a baby a newborn
baby for the first time a baby
imprints on a child oh [ __ ] that's yeah
imprints on a child a baby a baby
this later like even epstein would be
like the [ __ ] is wrong with you
right that's true super weird and then
later he goes no no it's not even like
that
it's not even like that i can't decide
yeah pedophiles can't decide either
whether they like kids or not
the baby starts aging exponentially fast
the baby's looking like seven years
old later on there's a scene at the end
of the movie where the [ __ ] wolf
jacob looks at edward and they're both
looking at edward's kid
and jacob's soon-to-be thing and jacob
goes
so should i start calling you dad now
huh why are we joking around about this
the [ __ ] that could see the future i
forget her name
what's happening yo shut up you ruined
it
you're ruining momentum it's just listen
i'm on board he goes he goes in the
[ __ ] they can see the future starts to
look in the future of jacob
and the daughter right yeah she looks in
the future
and sees jacob and the daughter
being in a relationship and going away
together can she see you in the future
no but i imagine one style it might
happen
so i guess but my point is how crazy is
it like they tease it and you're like
they're not really gonna go there
yeah and they went there and nobody
there's nothing wrong with that that's
not a problem
nah but wait why did he imprint on the
baby was it like a [ __ ] you i can't
decide i can't decide it's not up to me
what yeah it's up to the writer who
decided that
i just don't want to decide that
imprints on any of these vampire [ __ ]
you imprinted a [ __ ] child
yeah that's weird bruh yeah that's
problematic and short he was aging in
dog years too like she was aging mad
fast remember
so maybe there's something there but
that's not weird bro it has to be on a
baby though right
no 18 year old girl why not
only imprinting that happened on a child
everybody else imprinted as adults
everybody else is with adults and he
sees a kid for the first time this
[ __ ] pedophile weirdo
yeah and just starts howling
red rocket pops out probably the red
rocket with the lipstick
matt gross like what are you doing dude
son that's not weird twilight
that's weird that's weird that's weird
with all the problematic [ __ ] you see in
movies that we will talk about oh look
at this there's not enough diversity
there's not enough this
there's actual pedophilia yeah but women
won't cancel women fun they will only
cancel our fun
it's gotta be something men like for it
to be problematic this is women's
michael jackson
you know how we love michael jackson so
much we looking past that [ __ ] right
they love jacob so much that he admits
to being a pedophile in the movie and
they're like
but the body
[Laughter]
do the wolves live a long time or is it
just the vampires well
i don't know i was going live
i was gonna lie but then i don't know
because that would make it double creepy
if he was mad old also
if he was a super old [ __ ] no werewolves
can only die from silver bullets right
no all the rules change and they just
change rule for vampires they change
rule for everything
60 years and then the vampire's 150 to
200 average age no
vampires live forever in that one yeah
and they say
where are you getting this you're
wikipedia stupid they're also not
werewolves
wait what are they they're just wolves
they're native americans that are also
part wolf and they only get to turn into
wolves and vampires are around
uh they need vampires
so they can't kill the vampires all i'm
saying is if native americans turned
into animals maybe we did a right damn
and we shouldn't there should have been
a genocide there should not have been
right did we genocide them
but if they did we have diseases that
they didn't have and we had them because
we was living around animals
they talking all that [ __ ] about how
animal-like they are but where the
disease is at
you know what i mean this whole life i'm
chief you know uh [ __ ]
eagle face right it's like maybe if you
spend some more time with the eagles
if they live with you you would develop
some of the diseases they got and then
you would be
you know oh that's a good point
impervious to disease like whites
this is what we did we lived around the
[Applause]
livestock
you